- - Pour : 78. Contre : 29.
A À peine adoptée, un vent
dede contestation judiciaire
sosouffle déjà contre la loi 96.
LeLe gouvernement Legault affire
avavoir une position équilibréet
reresponsable, mais cette loi
popourra-t-elle être rapidement
apappliquée? Le ministre
SiSimon Jolin-Barrette sort
totout juste d'une commission
paparlementaire à Québec. Bonso.
- - Bonsoir.
PrPrenant ceux qui ont voté cone
lala loi parce qu'il trouve qu's
vovont trop loin, je prends
exexemple sur l'interrogatoire e
lala charte des droits est
sususpendu pour faire valoir
l'l'importance du français, este
quque ce sont des arguments qui
vovous préoccupent?
- - Écoutez, dans un sujet aussi
imimportant, il doit venir aux
élélus québécois, pour être
cecertain que la loi... surtout
ququ'elle ne soit pas charcutée
cocomme la loi 101 a été charcue
auau cours des années.
LeLes Français étaient avérés et
ilil faut prendre des mesures
cocostaudes pour cela avéré.
- - Je vous soumets les critiqus
anannoncés plus tout à l'heure,
vovous ne les avez pas entendusu
écécoutés, pourquoi ne pas avoir
étété plus souple sur cette
ququestion, six mois si peu pour
apapprendre le français.
- - Le principe de base convie
d'd'intégrer dans le projet de i
9696, c'est l'exemplarité de
l'l'État en matière de français,
ilil doit s'exprimer exclusivemt
enen français.
OnOn a fait une marge de manoeue
popour l'État québécois, avec
l'l'accueil de nouveaux avérés
vevent, une période de transiti,
popour pouvoir se trouver un
ememploi, un logement, inscrire
leles enfants à l'école.
IlIl faut choisir le français, e
plplus grand défi, relativement
dédéclin de l'français, c'est le
tataux de substitution
lilinguistique pour les personns
mimigrantes, quelle langue choie
ststyle?
LeLe tout est d'environ 55 %, il
fafaut retrouver un taux vers 90
%.%.
AvAvec francisation Québec on mt
enen place, les facteurs
d'd'intégration, on doit
acaccueillir en français au
QuQuébec, et on doit avoir les
ououtils pour.
- - Évidemment c'est en six moi,
popour vous excuserez capable
d'd'apprendre en six mois si vos
allez ailleurs une autre langue.
- - L'État québécois donne des
seservices publics est à des ges
auau Québec qui ne parle ni
ananglais ni français.
IlIl existe des traducteurs, mas
ilil faut arrêter d'utiliser
sysystématiquement l'anglais par
l'l'État québécois, sinon le
memessage qu'on envoie,... c'est
çaça notre plus grand défi Madae
DuDussault.
- - En terminant, la question ds
seservices de santé, il y en a
bebeaucoup qui craigne qu'ils vt
êêtre privés de pouvoir
s's'exprimer en anglais.
MoMonsieur Legault a dit
auaujourd'hui que peu importe lr
ororigine pourront être servie n
ananglais.
- - Rien dans le projet de loi
n'n'affecte les droits de la
cocommunauté anglaise, avant le
prprojet de loi 96, il pouvait e
fafaire soigner en anglais, et
apaprès l'adoption de l'projet e
loloi 96 ils pourront continuerà
sese faire servir en anglais, rn
n'n'affecte les services de san,
j'j'ai même accepté un dépôt
d'd'amendement pour venir rassur
l'l'ensemble de la communauté
ananglophone.
MaMalheureusement, beaucoup de
fafaussetés ont été dites, des
gegens tentent de faire peur au
momonde, et ce n'est pas vrai qe
leles services de santé ne serot
plplus donnés en langue anglaise
popour les gens qui le demanden.
LaLa loi 96 ne chang